foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the Wizarding afterlife
taking a closer look at what exactly
happens to witches and wizards when they
die the line between the living and the
dead is unquestionably a blurry one in
Harry Potter this is reinforced by the
prevalence of beings that skirt these
two planes of existence ghosts and
Dementors are some of the first that
come to mind and with these Blurred
Lines the topic of death which is also a
key thematic element in Harry Potter
becomes even more alluring in fact one
of the main messages of the Harry Potter
books is that death is not absolute it's
also reinforced that it's not anything
we should be worrying about we're
continually reminded that death is
simply a part of life and that rather
than obsessing over it we should instead
shift our focus on seeking love and
friendship enjoying the time that we do
have Voldemort infamously tried to evade
which is why his name is aptly derived
from the French Voldemort meaning flight
of death but the lesson the books teach
surrounding the inevitability of death
is one that never quite resonated with
our immortality obsessed antagonist
rather than Embrace Life at its own pace
Voldemort devised all sorts of plans to
achieve the ever elusive goal of
immortality on a side note there are
actually five methods of achieving
immortality in Harry Potter if you're
curious about them check out my video
all five methods of immortality in Harry
Potter though life and death have
Blurred Lines but what exactly does that
mean what happens to a witch or wizard
when they die why do some become ghosts
is there an afterlife the soul the first
thing we need to focus on is the
existence of the soul that is the life
force by which corporeal and incorporeal
form can be distinguished the existence
of a soul is a somewhat abstract concept
which means it's hard to Define however
the generally accepted concept of a soul
is that it's a kind of immaterial
spiritual Essence an actuating cause of
an individual's life it's what makes us
tick and it certainly has no scientific
explanation it's the soul that Dementors
feed on its pieces of soul that
Voldemort imparts into objects and it's
the soul that Avada Kedavra purportedly
rips out of the body the soul is what
keeps our corporeal form Earthbound and
that's why it plays a significant role
in the conversation surrounding the
Wizarding afterlife
you can exist without your soul you know
as long as your brain and heart are
still working but you'll have no sense
of self anymore no memory no anything
there's no chance at all of recovery
you'll just exist as an empty shell and
your soul is gone forever last Harry
Potter very much perpetuates the idea
that ultimately the physical body is
merely a shell a vessel that merely
transports the vital life force within
and because the soul is immaterial it
exists forever it's also reinforced that
unless you live a particularly cursed
existence like Voldemort then the Soul
won't be affected by death and the
subsequent exit from The Immortal Realm
look if I picked up a sword right now
Ron and ran you through with it I
wouldn't damage your soul at all which
would be a real Comfort to me I'm sure
said Ron hurry laughed it should be
actually but my point is that whatever
happens to your body your soul will
survive
untouched said Hermione in fact it seems
as though in most cases quite the
opposite happens with the soul becoming
vitalized or purified and reverting the
individual back to their Prime State
this is reinforced through Harry's
interaction with the souls of his loved
ones in the Forbidden Forest Sirius was
tall and handsome and younger by far
than Harry had seen him in life he loped
with an easy Grace his hands in his
pockets and a grin on his face Lupine
was younger too and much less shabby and
his hair was thicker and darker he
looked happy to be back in this familiar
Place scene of so many adolescent
wanderings in the case of Voldemort
however he wasn't so lucky Harry turned
slowly on the spot and his surroundings
seemed to invent themselves before his
eyes he had spotted the thing that was
making the noises it had the form of a
small naked child curled on the ground
its skin raw and rough played looking
and it lays shuddering under a seat
where it had been left unwanted starved
out of sight struggling for breath
though many interpreted the child on the
floor of King's cross to be
representative of the Soul fragment
expelled from Harry's body it turns out
it was actually representative of the
current state of Voldemort's Soul what
exactly was the mutilated baby-like
creature Harry saw King's cross in
chapter 35 of Hallows I've been asked
this a lot it is the last piece of Soul
Voldemort possesses okay so you die and
presumably your soul vacates your
physical body what happens next as it
would appear witches and wizards
actually get to choose their fate
deciding between moving on to the
afterlife or remaining in the world of
the living however there is a catch to
remaining in the Mortal realm you won't
possess any kind of physical form the
decision to return to the world of the
living can be reflected by ghosts in
Harry Potter who make the choice to
return to the Mortal plane usually due
to unfinished business however here's
the thing about remaining as a ghost you
are just a shell of your former self
kind of similar to the shades produced
by the resurrection Stone you aren't
alive and you aren't dead which means
that you can never truly move on it's a
bit of an empty existence per Pottermore
Muggles cannot come back as ghosts and
the wisest witches and wizards choose
not to it is those with unfinished
business whether in the form of fear
guilt regrets or overt attachment to the
material world who refuse to move on to
the next Dimension should a ghost choose
to remain in the land of the living due
to this unfinished business they should
expect a very different existence than
what they had during their mortality the
existence of a ghost is rather shunted
as they are no longer able to derive any
kind of physical pleasure nor are they
capable of learning new things the worst
part of being a ghost however is that
the harbor resentments that they had
from their mortality for the remainder
of their existence rendering them
entirely incapable of moving past things
this sounds more and more like a bad
decision okay so some make the decision
to return but where exactly do they make
this decision limbo after being killed
by Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest
Harry found himself in a place filled
with mist that looked like King's cross
station but this place wasn't King's
cross at all it was Limbo limbo in many
religions can be described as the Border
plays Between Heaven and Hell a place
where lost souls go before moving on to
the afterlife it's a place where one is
neither dead nor alive a place that's
often perceived as a forgotten or
ignored Place many different religions
cultures view limbo differently however
one aspect of limbo is can consistent
across all of them it's not somewhere
that you want to be most outline that
limbo is the place that a recently
deceased person can make a choice move
on to the afterlife or return to the
world as a ghost which is consistent
with Harry Potter however JK Rowling
also stated that limbo was somewhere you
could be trapped if your soul was
damaged JK Rowling confirmed in an
interview that because Voldemort had
destroyed his soul with horcruxes he
would be permanently stuck there a place
that interestingly enough would have
been a stark reminder a Voldemort's
formative years when he was laughed at
War's orphanage as a baby and with two
out of the three options for lost souls
already discussed purgatory and limbo or
returning to the world of living as a
ghost all that's left is the Final
Destination the afterlife when
discussing the process of becoming a
ghost with Harry nearly headless Nick
goes on to state that very few Wizards
would choose the path he chose implying
that there is some form of life after
death an option other than returning to
the Mortal realm this is again
reinforced through the existence of open
channels of communication between the
land of the living and the Land of the
Dead namely the veil and the
resurrection Stone in fact in the
presence of the veil which is considered
as a sort of Gateway between the land of
living and dead Luna Harry Ginny and
Neville were all entranced hearing the
voices of their deceased loved ones from
Beyond he had the strangest feeling that
there was someone standing right behind
the veil on the other side of the
archway gripping his wand very tightly
he edged around the Deus but there was
nobody there all that could be seen was
the other side of the tattered Black
Veil and via the resurrection Stone Ari
was able to quite clearly communicate
with shades of lost loved ones implying
they do exist somewhere the afterlife in
Harry Potter is never clearly defined
but what is clear is that it's the best
place you can go upon dying an idyllic
Place akin to a state of Nirvana here
your soul lives on in its purified state
in a place with all of the other Souls
that made the same decision to move on a
place where its subjects are released
from the cycle of death and rebirth we
know that the Wizarding World is aware
of the concept of hell as Neville
Longbottom once references it but if
Voldemort's fate is anything to go by
then remaining in limbo is likely the
Wizarding World equivalent and that's it
for this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember to
the well-organized Mind death is what
the next great adventure
foreign